[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Christian
sieers guten Abend ihn allen die Bilder
die wir Ihnen jetzt zeigen betreffen
mindestens 5 Millionen Menschen in
Deutschland jeden Tag ganz direkt und
viele weitere Millionen darüber
hinaus das hier ist der Hauptbahnhof in
Köln einer der meist frequentierten
deutschen Fernbahnhöfe mit
Gleisen also
normalerweise seit heute geht nicht mehr
viel die Gewerkschaft der Lockführer hat
den bislang längsten Streik gestartet in
der Geschichte der Bahn AG noch bis
Montagabend soll das so weitergehen die
Kosten für das Land gehen in die
Hunderte million
Ärger und Nervereien nicht
mitgerechnet bemerkenswert auch dass
aktuell gar nicht absehbar ist wann es
weitere Verhandlungen geben soll sprich
auch nach Ende dieses Streiks keine
Lösung in Sicht stattdessen wohl eher
der nächste Streik es lohnt sich also
mal zu gucken woran es tatsächlich haakt
und was jetzt nötig wäre zumal es
zunehmend so wirkt als ob sich beide
Seiten auch jenseits der inhaltlichen
Fragen mittlerweile ganz persönlich gehö
auf die Nerven gehen Oliver
Heuchert draußen vom Hamburger
Hauptbahnhof stehen die Streikenden von
der GDL der Gewerkschaft deutscher
Lokomotivführer drinnen im Hamburger
Hauptbahnhof sind die Gleise leer
währenddessen ist der Chef der
Gewerkschaft angriffslustig wie immer
wir müssen länger und auch härter
streigen weil das Management der Bahn
beratungsresistent ist wir haben kurze
Streiks gemacht wir haben warenstreiks
begonnen dann haben wir eine Abstimmung
gemacht 97% der Mitarbeiter der
Deutschen Bahn entscheiden sich für
Streiks gegen das eigene Management die
GDL fordert derzeit 240 € monatliche
Lohnerhöhung ab Mai dieses Jahres und ab
Februar 2025 weitere 180 € 3000 €
inflationsausgleichsprämie will die GDL
außerdem die GDL verlangt für alle die
regelmäßig Schichtarbeit leisten eine 35
Stundenwoche stufenweise bis
Laufzeit 24
Monate die Bahn bietet derzeit 4,8%
Lohnerhöhung ab August und 5% ab April
2850 €
inflationsausgleichsprämie und eine 37
Stunden Woche oder
2,7% weitere Lohnerhöhung
2026 Laufzeit 32
Monate wir als Deutsche Bahn haben
zuletzt Verhandlungsbereitschaft
signalisiert wir wollten diesen
sechstägigen Streik verhindern das war
unser Ziel und wir waren und wir sind
immer noch verhandlungsbereit egal zu
welcher Zeit an welchem Ort wir sind da
wir sind der Meinung man muss an den
Tisch kommen man muss zu Kompromissen
finden die Gleise sind allerdings auch
deswegen oft so leer weil bahnag und GDL
das Verhandeln so schwer fällt wir haben
in diesem Konzern eine uner iche Kultur
des Kampfes zwischen Management und
Gewerkschaft insbesondere der GDL die
GDL ist eine kleine Bahngewerkschaft hat
nur knapp 40.000 Mitglieder die große
Bahngewerkschaft die Eisenbahn und
Verkehrsgewerkschaft EVG hat mehr als
180.000 Mitglieder diese Aggression hat
mehrere Ursachen die erste Ursache ist
dass wieselski immer in dem Ton antritt
die wollen mich und uns hier platt
machen wir als GDL haben ja eigentlich
keine
Existenzberechtigung in diesem
bahnkorporatismus der über viele
Jahrzehnte zwischen der großen
Gewerkschaft und dem bahnmanagement
gesteuert wird und jetzt kommen wir als
Spielverderber auf den Platz das
Verhältnis GDL und bahnage ist
einigermaßen Verfahren kaum jemand denkt
dass dieser Arbeitskampf ohne eine
Schlichtung beendet werden kann damit
die Streiks doch noch irgendwann einmal
aufhören Volker wiessing ist der
Bundesverkehrsminister er ist jetzt bei
uns vom Frankfurter Flughafen aus da
kommt man aktuell ja auch besser weg als
vom Bahnhof guten Abend Herr
wiessing guten Abend Herr Sivers der
längste Streik in der Geschichte der
deutschen bahnag wie lange schauen Sie
sich das noch
an ich habe mich ja jetzt deutlich
geäußert ich war die ganze Zeit
zurückhaltend aber das nimmt jetzt
Ausmaße an die so nicht mehr hinnehmbar
sind und deswegen habe ich in aller
Klarheit gesagt jetzt muss ein
Schlichtungsverfahren her mindestens
eine Mediation und vor allen Dingen muss
so schnell wie möglich am
Verhandlungstisch gesprochen werden
jetzt sagen Sie man bräuchte eine
Schlichtung nur Sie wissen auch die
Chancen für so eine Schlichtung aktuell
sind ausgesprochen gering Experten
rechnen in der Zwischenzeit mit einem
volkswirtschaftlichen Schaden von
insgesamt mehr als einer halben
Milliarde Euro Herr Wissing brauchen wir
gesetzliche Regel die Streiks in Zukunft
bei so einem wichtigen Betrieb Stichwort
kritische Infrastruktur einschränken
oder zumindest verbinden mit einer
Schlichtung die vor einem Streik dann
quasi immer vorgeschrieben sein
sollte zunächst einmal können wir nicht
jeden Tarifkonflikt mit einer
Gesetzesänderung begleiten und klar ist
auch wenn tarifkonflikte sich zuspitzen
dass es dann immer zu einer verhärteten
Situation kommt das ist aber nicht
Aufgabe des bundesg Gesetzgeber ist das
zu lösen sondern es ist Aufgabe der
Tarifpartner verantwortungsvoll sich zu
verhalten und das heißt einen Kompromiss
auszuhandeln es ist nichts
ungewöhnliches in einer Demokratie dass
es an verschiedenen Stellen Konflikte
gibt es ist aber ungewöhnlich dass man
diese Konflikte frontal lösen möchte
ohne kompromissbereit zu sein wir
brauchen einen Kompromiss zwischen den
beiden Tarifparteien der Ausgleich
zwischen den Tarifpartnern das ist die
Lösung und das ist auch das was unsere
Verfassung am
verlangt aber jetzt sagt die
Gewerkschaft es gebe es gibt
Verhandlungsergebnisse bereits mit den
anderen also mit kleineren
Eisenbahnverkehrsunternehmen und die
Gewerkschaft sieht das als mögliche
Kompromisslinie auch in den
Verhandlungen mit der Deutschen Bahn so
schlimm können also die Forderungen der
Gewerkschaft ja gar nicht sein wenn die
anderen Eisenbahnunternehmen darauf
eingegangen sind
oder
es ist nicht me der Aufgabe diese Dinge
zu bewerten vor allen Dingen kann ich
die auch selbst nicht nach nachprüfen
und deswegen ist das nicht der Punkt das
Entscheidende ist es gibt eine Forderung
der GDL und es ist auch klar dass die
Bahn das wäre ja ungewöhnlich in einem
Tarifkonflikt einfach eins zu eins
akzeptiert was von ihr gefordert wird
sondern normal ist es dass man einen
Kompromiss aushandelt und der kann nur
zustande kommen wenn man sich am
Verhandlungstisch befindet wenn man
seitens der GDL sagt wir gehen nicht an
den Verhandlungstisch wir erwarten
einfach ein Jahr der Bahn zu unseren
Forderungen dann ist das nicht mehr
konstruktiv und schon gar nicht ist es
akzeptabel dass ein solches Verhalten zu
einem derart großen
volkswirtschaftlichen Schaden führt ich
fordere dass man sich hier
verantwortungsbewusst verhält jetzt hat
man das wenden sie auch mitbekommen
haben Herr wising so ein bisschen den
Eindruck es geht nicht mehr nur um die
Sache sondern zunehmend auch um
Befindlichkeiten also da fallen Worte
wie Vollpfosten Nieten im
Nadelstreifen von Seiten der GDL
Richtung Bahn die Bahn sagt die GDL will
mit dem Kopf durch die Wand haben Sie
den Eindruck das sind da zwei Parteien
die sich gegenseitig auch ganz
persönlich nicht ausstehen können und
auch deshalb nicht
vorankommen
genau diese Dinge Herr sie sind es die
mich veranlasst haben jetzt mal
deutliche Worte zu gebrauchen denn diese
Emotionalisierung eines Tarifkonfliktes
ist nicht akzeptabel die
Verantwortlichen müssen sich ja drüber
im Klaren sein was das bedeutet für
Menschen die zur Arbeit wollen die ihre
Termine wahrnehmen müssen was es für
Unternehmen bedeutet die Güter
transportieren müssen die Waren erhalten
müssen und dann sich so zu verhalten mit
der Art merkwürdigen Begriffen sich zu
bewerfen das ist nicht das was man
erwartet wenn es um die Frage geht
verantwortungsvoll ein Tarifkonflikt zu
lösen und deswegen muss das sofort
beendet werden wir brauchen eine
Schlichtung jetzt können sie appellieren
natürlich an beide Seiten so richtig
Einfluss haben sie aber auf die eine
Seite nämlich die Bahn die dem Bund
gehört haben sie da mal so intern gesagt
Leute also so geht's jetzt nicht weiter
ihr müsst jetzt auch wirklich gehörig
mal auf die Gewerkschaft
zugehen Herr auch wenn die Bahn dem Bund
gehört ist der Bund nicht Tarifpartner
wir sind nicht Partei in diesem
Tarifkonflikt und wir müssen schon ein K
geben oder sagen wir so vielleicht
verpacken als als Ratschlag des
Eigentümers selbstverständlich
bin ich in einem engen Austausch undon
in Gesprächen auch mit der Deutschen
Bahn und mit dem Vorstand aber klar ist
dass ohne dass die GDL sich an den
Verhandlungstisch begibt ja ein
Kompromiss nicht vom Himmel fallen kann
er muss ja erst mal erarbeitet werden
und was ich nicht akzeptieren kann ist
dass man streikt aber nicht parallel
auch einen Kompromiss erarbeitet und das
muss jetzt schnell beendet werden
deswegen sofort zurück an den
Verhandlungstisch schnell einen
Kompromiss ausarbeiten und nicht auf
maximalfderungen beharren sagt der
Bundesverkehrsminister Volker Wissing
herzlichen Dank für das Gespräch her
Wissing ich danke
Ihnen das Gespräch haben wir aus
Termingründen am frühen Abend
aufgezeichnet und noch ein
heute abend kündigt die
Pilotengewerkschaft Cockpit an beim
Ferienflieger discover Airlines werde
jetzt am Freitag die Arbeit niedergelegt
das betrifft die Abflüge der
lufthansertochter von deutschen
Flughäfen es geht dabei um den Abschluss
von Tarifverträgen die Verhandlungen
darüber hatte die Gewerkschaft im Januar
für gescheitert
erklärt
er hat gewonnen aber nicht so gewaltig
wie er sich das vorgestellt hatte und
sie weigert sich jetzt einfach so das
Feld zu räumen das ist in zwei Sätzen
das Ergebnis der Vorwahlen der
Republikaner im usbundesstaat New
Hampshire jetzt sieht alles danach aus
dass Donald Trump deren Kandidat werden
wird fürs Weiße Haus again aber
einhundertprozentig sicher ist das nicht
seine einzige verbliebene Konkurrentin
Nicki Haley jedenfalls will
weiterkämpfen Claudia Bates hat die
Details der legendäre red arrower in
Politiker lassen sich hier gerne
fotografieren und die Gäste kennen sich
aus Vater und Tochter TH bewerten das
Wahlergebnis sehr unterschiedlich ich
bin froh wenn die Trump Politik
wiederkommt als Person finde ich ihn
nicht so
toll ich hatte gehofft wir würden nicht
wieder ein Rennen zwischen Trump und
beiden bekommen Washington und das Land
brauchen jemand frisches jüngeres mit
neuen
ideench diese Chung geblieben dennoch
eine streitlustige Nicki Haley sagt
Trump den Kampf an stellt seine
geistigen Fähigkeiten in Frage und für
ihn das Schlimmste zeichnet ihn als
Verlierer mit Donald Trump haben wir
fast jede Wahl verloren wir haben den
Senat verloren wir haben das
Repräsentantenhaus verloren wir haben
das Weiße Haus verloren die Demokraten
wollen dass Trump
[Applaus]
antritt denn sie wissen er ist der
einzige Republikaner den beiden schlagen
kann schon ihre scharfe Kritik reizte
Trump aber dann kam der Satz der für ihn
unerträglich
war dieses Rennen ist noch lang nicht
vorbei Trump sauer dass sie vor ihm ihre
Rede hält vor allem aber dass sie nicht
demütig ausscheidet er antwortet mit
Häme wer zur Hölle war die hochstalerin
die gerade auf der Bühne stand und
sprach als hätte sie
Schle sie hätte hier gewinnen
müssen Minuten weiter in der Rede kommt
er noch mal darauf zurück so wütend ist
er man kann Leute einfach nicht mit so
einem Bullshit davon kommen lassen als
ich sie auf die Bühne kommen sah in
ihrem schicken Kleid na ja vielleicht
nicht so schick da sagte ich was macht
sie da wir haben
gewonnen füriden ist damit klar wer sein
Gegner sein bei der Präsidentschaftswahl
im November und er reagiert direkt mit
einem Kernthema seines
Wahlkampfs seid ihr bereit die
Demokratie zu
verteidigen seid ihr bereit unsere
Freiheiten zu
schützen seid ihr bereit diese Wahl zu
gewinnen der wahlzirkus zieht weiter mit
Trump als Chef der
manäe ja und ein paar interessante Dinge
hat new Hamp durchaus noch gezeigt und
deswegen reden wir jetzt noch mit BA in
Manchester New Hampshire schön
verschneit wie immer zu dieser Zeit
guten Abend Claudia Trump hat gewonnen
und gleichzeitig Schwächen gezeigt wo
liegen die
Schwächen also neben allem anderen was
man über Trump sagen kann hat er drei
klare Schwächen im Hinblick auf die
Präsidentschaftswahl die eine ist dass
er die Zeit des Wahlkampfs zu einem
nicht unerheblichen Anteil ja in
gerichtsseelen zubringen muss und noch
vor der Wahl könnte er ein verurteilter
Straftäter sein die zweite Schwäche wird
zunehmend sein Alter und Nicki haey hat
das klar benannt und andere tun es
inzwischen auch und zu guter Letzt hat
er zwar die republikanische Basis fest
im Griff aber Wechselwähler und moderate
Republikaner nicht und ohne diese Wähler
der Mitte kann er die Präsidentschaft
nicht gewinnen also das ist eine
Herausforderung für die Republikaner und
wie kann man Nicki Halys Strategie jetzt
beschreiben wie lange wird sie
durchhalten kann man das sagen bis auch
sie dann das Feld räumt für
Trump ja Nicki hay will auf jeden Fall
durchhalten bis zum sogenannten Super
Tuesday Anfang März an dem mehr als ein
Dutzend Staaten wählen ob ihr das
gelingt ist vor allem auch eine
Geldfrage sie hat mächtige Geldgeber die
gehofft hatten dass es innerhalb der
republikanischen Partei eine Alternative
zu Trump geben könnte und da die Frage
nun geklärt ist werden wesentliche
Geldquellen möglicherweise versiegen
ihre Strategie sie will sich als Zukunft
der republikanischen Partei jetzt in
Stellung bringen entweder kurzfristig in
der Hoffnung dass Trump über einen
seiner Skandale stolpert oder dann eben
für die Zeit nach Trump die Analyse von
Claudia Bates ZDF Manchester New
Hampshire vielen Dank
Claudia die Nachrichten beginnen mit
einem Blick auf den Krieg im Nahen Osten
der tobt weiterhin und erfordert schier
unerträglich viele Menschen leben und
zwar jeden Tag wieder Gundula aus
chanunis im Süden des gazaastreifens
werden schwere Kämpfe gemeldet nach
Angaben der Hamas sollen dabei mehr als
210 Palästinenser binnen eines Tages
getötet worden sein darunter laut UN
auch geflüchtete die Schutz gesucht
hatten in Israel haben
Frauenorganisationen zu einem Tag des
Zorns aufgerufen und blockieren
landesweit Straßen und Kreuzungen die
DemonstrantInnen fordern eine sofortige
Freilassung der rund 130 Geiseln die
noch seit dem 7 oktober in der Gewalt
der Hamas
sind das US-Militär hat erneut Ziele im
Irak und im Jemen bombardiert Reaktion
auf Raketen und Drohnenangriffe auf
amerikanische Truppen die Attacken
richteten sich unter anderem gegen
Stellungen der vom Iran unterstützten
hui Rebellen das US-Militär führt die
Angriffe gemeinsam mit britischen
Streitkräften durch und mit
Rückendeckung von 24 Staaten die das
Vorgehen verteidigen darunter
Deutschland Außenministerin bärbur hat
erneut bei einer Reise einen ungeplanten
Stopp einlegen müssen auf dem Weg nach
Ostafrika fehlte die
Überfluggenehmigung für
Eritrea wohl auch wegen eines
Stromausfalls bei den eritreischen
Behörden gerade eben wurde bei dem
ungeplanten Stopp in saudiarab Arabien
die geänderte Reiseroute bekannt gegeben
nun geht es morgen schon nach Kenia
statt erst nach djibuti denn auch ein
umfliegen Eritreas war nicht möglich im
letzten Sommer hatte bbock eine
Australienreise wegen eines technischen
Defekts abbrechen
müssen die Bundeswehr soll sich ein
weiteres Jahr an der NATO
seeüberwachungsmission im Mittelmeer und
an dem UN-Einsatz im Südsudan beteiligen
eine Verlängerung der Mandate bis Ende
März 2025 hat das Bundeskabinett
beschlossen der Bundestag muss noch
zustimmen an dem natoeinsatz beteiligen
sich derzeit 280 deutsche Soldaten
außerdem hat das Bundeskabinett einem
Gesetzentwurf von Familienministerin
Paus zugestimmt mit dem schwangere
Frauen vor Belästigungen durch
Abtreibungsgegner geschützt werden
sollen die Ampelkoalition reagiert damit
auf die zunehmenden Protestaktionen vor
Arztpraxen und Beratungsstellen diese
sogenannten
gsteigbelästigungen sollen künftig als
Ordnungswidrigkeit gearet werden mit
drohenden Bußgeldern von bis zu 5000
€ so und jetzt eine Nachricht bei der
vieles unklar ist so gut wie alles nicht
unabhängig überprüft und die dennoch
aufhorchen lässt Russland beschuldigt
die Ukraine ein
militärtransportflugzeug abgeschossen zu
haben in der russischen Grenzregion zur
Ukraine es handle sich um einen
barbarischen Terrorakt gegen eine
Maschine vom Typ ilushin
il76 sagt das Außenministerium in Moskau
alle 74 Menschen an Bord sein tot und
darunter sein so sagt Russland auch 65
Kriegsgefangene aus der
Ukraine bringen wir unsere
Korrespondenten mit dazu zunächst Anne
Brühl in Kiev Anne wie sind denn die
Reaktionen
dort
fast schon Verhalten klar ist dieser
Austausch der Kriegsgefangenen der war
für heute geplant die ukrainische Seite
war vorbereitet von russischer Seite
heißt es hier habe es keinerlei
spezielle Anforderungen gegeben wie
sonst durchaus üblich was z.B den
Luftraum über belgorot
betrefft
betrifft
außerdem wartet man jetzt hier an diesem
Abend auf die Ansprache von Präsident
selenski denn es gibt immer noch keine
offizielle Erklärung auch kein Dementi
der Generalstab hat am Abend erklärt man
werde weiter russische
Transportflugzeuge angreifen weil die
Ukraine in diesen Flugzeugen eben S300
Raketen vermute das sind die Raketen mit
denen die Russen immer wieder vor allen
Dingen hakiv die zweitgrößte Stadt der
Ukraine angreifen was hier den ganzen
Tag aber auch auffällig war waren
stimmen die davor gewarnt haben
voreilige Schlüsse zu ziehen auch
russische
Desinformationskampagnen wurden als eine
Möglichkeit erachtet aber klar ist
natürlich auch wenn in diesem Flugzeug
wirklich ukrainische Kriegsgefangene
gesessen haben dann wäre das für die
Ukrainer eine
tragödiein Körper ist unser Moskau
Korrespondent Amin guten Abend ist denn
absehbar wann und ob wir irgendwann dann
tatsächlich Klarheit bekommen können was
da tatsächlich passiert
ist ich denke das wird icht die
russische Seite hat zwar eine Kommission
angekündigt die das untersuchen soll hat
ihre Experten an die Absturzstelle
geschickt gleichzeitig hat man sich aber
ja längst festgelegt was da angeblich
passiert sei das sieht man z.B daran
dass Außenminister lavrov heute schon
bei den Vereinten Nationen eine
sicherheitsratsitzung in dieser
Angelegenheit gefordert hat die
russische Seite betont immer wieder es
hätte einen Funkspruch des Piloten
gegeben dass die Maschine angegriffen
würde man hätte auch bildbelege von den
Raketen die auf ukrainischer Seite
abgeschossen worden sein allein wir
haben diese Belege nie gesehen was mir
aber auch auffällt ist dass auf
ukrainischer Seite Onlinemedien sehr
schnell gemeldet haben man habe eine
russische Militärmaschine abgeschossen
das wurde dann als die Russen diese
Kriegsgefangenen ins spielbrachten von
ukrainischen Medien wieder relativiert
bzw gelöscht und auch da eine
Untersuchung angekündigt also ich denke
es mag ein Zufall sein aber die sind
hier selten heute ist der 700 Kriegstag
und wir sind auf den Tag genau einen
Monat vor dem zweiten Jahrestag des
ukrainekriegs da versuchen beide Seiten
natürlich ihre Erzählungen international
un das Volk zu bringen also das war das
was wir für den Moment sicher wissen es
bleiben aber noch viele Fragen ganz
herzlichen Dank Anna und
Amin und nachher im heute journal Update
noch ein Gespräch dazu mit dem
Militärexperten Christian
Mölling das Ziel des EU-Gipfels nächste
Woche ist dass alle EU-Staaten die
geplanten Militärhilfen für die Ukraine
gemeinsam beschließen so hat das der
Bundeskanzler heute abend gesagt und
dabei seinen Gast im Blick gehabt der
ist nämlich aus Sicht der
Bundesregierung ein schwieriger Gast der
neue Ministerpräsident der Slowakei ist
zu Besuch die Slowakei ist ein kleines
Land war aber unter der
Vorgängerregierung bei den ukrainhilfen
sehr großzügig der neue an der Macht
Robert fizzo schimpft dagegen bei jeder
Gelegenheit auf Europa und gerade hat er
gesagt die Ukraine sei gar kein
souveränes Land ob er seinen Worten auch
Taten folgen lässt das ist die Frage
heute nicht nur in Berlin Andreas Künast
ungefähr zu der Zeit als Viktor in den
unterirdischen schlafsal führt und von
den 60 Kindern erzählt die hierhin
geflohen waren und dann trotzdem
verletzt wurden durch die Scherben und
Splitter bei einem weiteren Angriff auf
Kiev ungefähr zu der Zeit wird der
Ministerpräsident der Slowakei nach der
Lage in Kiev
gefragt glauben Sie wirklich dass in
Kiev Krieg ist sie machen wohl Witze das
meinen sie doch nicht ernst das Leben
dort ist absolut
normal so laut und so heftig Roberto
fizzo für gewöhnlich die Ukraine
kritisiert die kein sveränes Land und
die vollständig unter dem Einfluss der
USA stehe so leise und so höflich war er
heute dort nur eben nicht in Kiev
sondern in der Grenzstadt uschgorott und
nur eben nicht mit seinen üblichen
Kampfansagen sondern dem
Versprechen wir wollen euch wirklich
beistehen wir wollen euch wirklich
helfen wer ist Roberto fizzo ein
verkannter Helfer mit rauer Schale oder
ein zweiter Viktor Orban ein neuer
Problem premier für die
EU man muss der Ukraine sagen ihr seid
eines der korruptesten Länder der Welt
nicht einmal Gott weiß wie viel von all
der Hilfe verloren geht es ist von
ungewollter Ironie dass ausgerechnet
fizzo der Ukraine ausgerechnet
Korruption vorwirft seit Wochen
protestieren in der Slowakei ztausende
gegen die Abschaffung der
Staatsanwaltschaft die für die
Bekämpfung der Korruption zuständig ist
wer Robert fzo
auf dem
Plakat eine
Rat wir wollen nicht dass solche
Zustände wie in Ungarn auch bei uns in
Bratislava
einziehen was Herr fitzo macht ist
unvorstellbar am Abend Berlin fizzo
kommt direkt aus der Ukraine nach
Deutschland und schimpft kaum ist er weg
wie vorher auf Kiev dafür ist er sehr
nett zu Kanzler Scholz und verspricht 50
Milliarden Programm der EU nicht zu
blockieren die Slowakei ist dabei jetzt
sagt einzig Ungarn noch Nein und da
hoffe ich dass es uns gelingt eine
Lösung mit 27 Mitgliedstaaten Zustande
zu kriegen das ist die Aufgabe die wir
jetzt vor uns haben und an der wir sehr
aktiv arbeiten sollten man kann Roberto
fizzo beim Wort nehmen heißt es im
Kanzleramt und das ist als Lob gemeint
denn es gibt viele Worte von fizzo die
als Kritik gemeint sind fast immer an
der
Ukraine
ich habe heute noch einmal die Ukrainer
gefragt was für Pläne haben sie die
einzige Antwort war Krieg keine anderen
Pläne der slowakische premier provoziert
und kooperiert und das gern gleichzeitig
es heißt man könne klarkmen mit ihm man
müsse nur wissen wer roberto fizzo
ist so jetzt an dieser Stelle in der
Sendung noch mal duund auch und gerade
die Softwarebranche setzt große
Hoffnungen auf künstliche Intelligenz so
hat der SAP Konzern nun eine kiofensive
angekündigt und einen weiteren
Stellenabbau Frank betmann was genau hat
SAP vor heute kündigten die waldorfer an
weltweit weitere 8000 Stellen abbauen zu
wollen mit dem Vormarsch der künstlichen
Intelligenz muss sich Europas größter
Softwarekonzern quasi neu erfinden neben
Angeboten zur Abfindung will man
versuchen Beschäftigte umzuschulen
gleich tig plant man auch für KI
qualifiziertes Personal neu einzustellen
insgesamt plant SAP für diesen
tiefgreifenden Umbau 2 Milliarden Euro
in die Hand zu nehmen und an der Börse
kommen die Pläne gut an die Aktie
klettert zwischenzeitlich auf ein neues
Allzeithoch und schließt mit
7,6% nur knapp darunter nach Ansicht der
Anleger dreht das DAX Schwergewicht also
offenbar an den richtigen Stellschrauben
in der Software BR ist die Konkurrenz ja
gerade beim Thema KI groß welche Chancen
hat da SAP na vorherrchende Meinung ist
dass SAP spät dran sei obwohl man im
vergangenen Jahr bereits eigene Produkte
wie den KI Assistenten Jul vorgestellt
hat Unternehmen die mit SAP Produkten
arbeiten sollen dadurch deutlich bessere
Ergebnisse erzielen können im
Personalwesen kommt Schul bereits zum
Einsatz bald soll der Assistent auch mit
der Software für Finanzen und Einkauf
funktionieren doch SAP steht damit erst
am Anfang und die Konkurrenz schläft
nicht macht Druck Frank betmann vielen
Dank wir kommen gleich zum Sport
zunächst die gewinnzahlen vom Lotto am
Mittwoch sie lauten ohne Gewehr 9 10 19
29 35 39 Superzahl 1 weitere
Gewinnzahlen auf Lotto zdfde und im ZDF
Text Tennisprofi alexander zwerf hat bei
den Australian Open das Halbfinale
erreicht zum zweiten Mal in seiner
Karriere mit einer fast fehlerlosen
Vorstellung besiegte er den
Weltranglisten zweiten Carlos alcaras
aus Spanien in vier Sätzen am Freitag
trifft ZEV dann auf seinen Dauerrivalen
den Russen Daniel
Medvedev und bei der handballem hat sich
die deutsche Mannschaft den riesentraum
Halbfinale im eigenen Land erfüllt
trotz einer Niederlage im letzten
Hauptrundenspiel gegen Kroatien denn
schon vor dem abschließenden Duell gegen
Kroatien hatte sich das dhbteam für das
Halbfinale qualifiziert durch die
Niederlagen von Ungarn und Österreich
gegen Kroatien verloren die deutschen
Handballer 24 Z 30 und müssen den
stimmungsdämpfer nun verkraften im
Halbfinale geht es am Freitagabend gegen
Dänemark live im ZDF ab 20 Uhr 15 das
andere Halbfinale ebenfalls live im ZDF
bestreiten zuvor Frankreich und
Schweden ja da freuen wir uns alle schon
drauf am Freitag jetzt aber erstmal
gleich nach uns da guckt das
auslandsjournal in ein Land das
eigentlich nicht nur wegen der
Galapagosinseln als Touristenparadies
gilt nach Ecuador nämlich jetzt ein Land
am Abgrund in dem das Militär selbst in
Fernsehstudios gegen die mächtigen
kokainartelle kämpft das jetzt gleich
nach s und wir zwei hier sagen Danke für
heute weisen aber noch schnell auf unser
heute journal Update hin gegen 0:30 mit
NAS gö bis morgen tschüss
[Musik]
tschüss guten Abend im 48 Stundent
überqueren uns gerade die Sturmtiefs das
Tief Jitka zieht morgen weiter nach
Osten und dann kommen schon die
Warmfront von den tief Katrin heran
dieses Tief Katrin wird dann am Freitag
vor allen Dingen an der Küste an der
Nord und Ostseeküste für viel Wind
sorgen dazwischen aber wird's
vorübergehend mal etwas ruhiger und das
hängt zusammen mit dem Hoch Dario dieses
Hoch Dario macht sich schon heute Nacht
bemerkbar denn es gibt doch nur noch
hier im Osten etwas Regen und auch am
alpenrad der Wind lässt auch allm etwas
nach und das wird noch mal eine milde
Nacht mit tiefstemperaturen zwischen 10°
am oberrehein und 2° in den östlichen
Mittelgebirgen morgen liegen dann die
Höchsttemperaturen in den Mittelgebirgen
so um 5° im Westen wird's da milder bei
9 bis 13° vor allen Dingen in
Norddeutschland wird das morgen ein
freundlicher Tag an der Küste werden sie
häufiger die Sonne zu Gesicht bekommen
einige Regenschauer gibt's noch hier im
südlichen Brandenburg in der Lausitz und
dann kommt die Warmfront von tief Katrin
heran das macht sich schon bemerkbar
durch diesen Regen und dieses Sturmtief
wird dann in der Nacht zu Freitag und
Freitag über Tag über Deutschland
hinwegziehen den meisten Wind bekommen
dann die Küsten ab bei Temperaturen von
6 bis 12°. am Wochenende aber beruhigt
sich das Wetter es gibt Sonnenschein
Nebel und Hochnebel und es wird auch ein
bisschen kälter am Samstag bei 3 bis 8
am Sonntag bei 4 bis 11° guten Abend